mic Don banks have said something
yesterday longtime NFL reporter that may
be behind the scenes were hearing NFL
owners looking at the Chargers situation
and could you see a scenario where they
would end up going back to San Diego
why would be hard to do because I think
one city that currently wants two
Chargers less than la would be San Diego
right they go back to San Diego and
10,000 people would show up for a home
game look I think that they made a
mistake in the leaving right away I know
they wanted to get to LA and compete
toe-to-toe with the Rams for the hearts
and minds and wallets of Los Angeles
fans but maybe there would have been
some benefit to hanging around San Diego
for a couple years I just think they
realized it was the point where it was
untenable with that annual question are
they leaving if they would have decided
to have a two or three year lame-duck
period that that wouldn't have been good
for anybody so they had to do something
and obviously this 27,000 seat stadium
isn't working because they can't sell it
out what what's best-case scenario here
for the Chargers well get through the
next three years hope your team improves
and hope that when this new stadium
opens that it is so impressive
state-of-the-art fabulous experience
that people will come to the games just
to be in the stadium right I mean that's
what we're hearing about it's great 2.6
billion dollar venue you're gonna pay
the money just to be there it's gonna be
so spectacular it's got to be something
like that to fill it up 20 times a year
when you factor in the preseason and the
regular-season game will it's still up
for the Rams games will it fill up for
the Chargers games and if we get to 2025
and there is a big disparity or if both
teams are struggling to fill it up at
some point the NFL has to say maybe we
just have one team there 10 times a year
filling it up versus it being 75 percent
66 percent capacity
20 different times between August and
December are you in on the rims not look
I'm in on their potential right it
reminds me a little bit and I don't want
to play this example Dan all the way out
to conclusion because it puts the Rams
in the Super Bowl but it reminds me of
the impact Jon Gruden
had on the buccaneers in 2002 where
you've got a defense that is very good
and then you bring in a guy who can stir
up the offense with a new system a new
approach a new attack get the most out
of the quarterback spread the football
around all these weapons that they have
and really more weapons on this Rams
team then John group has available to
him and the quarterback was Brad Johnson
all due respect to Brad Johnson so you
can balance out the Rams quickly and I
think the teams were true balance are
the teams that can be competitive and
and you look at the NFC West right now
the Seahawks are sputtering the
Cardinals have dipped the 49ers may be
on the path to becoming competitive but
they're all in three
I think the Rams all of a sudden or a
team that we have to watch and if they
can continue to balance offense and
defense
over the rest of the year maybe Shaun
McVeigh can push them into the
postseason he's Mike Florio pro football
talk.com NBC Sports Network and football
night in America what did you make of
the Aaron Hernandez results as far as
CTE with his brain and what does it mean
legally as we move forward whether it's
the University of Florida if it's the
NFL you know we're gonna see lawsuits
flying here well none of these CTE
results surprised me anymore because
we've come to the part where we accept
that people who play football for a
period of five 10 15 20 years are going
to have some degree of CTE we still
don't know what it means to have it we
don't know how else you can get it but
the bigger issue here as relates to the
legalities of this lawsuit already filed
by Jose Baez I can't help but wonder
whether or not he's trying to parlay
this into a little more promotion for
his career he's got a high profile
practice because unless Aaron Hernandez
Dan specifically opted out of the
concussion settlement I think he's gonna
have a hard time filing his own lawsuit
he last played in 2012 the case was
settled after that and the way it works
is if you were retired and he was de
facto retired from the NFL once he was
in prison your only path is to file a
claim within the confines of the
concussion settlement so he may be
better off making a claim against the
NCAA or Florida because it could be that
his legal status has already been
decided
with respect to the NFL and there's also
this reality I understand this is
something's being done for the benefit
of his daughter but you've got three
other families out there who have
wrongful death lawsuits pending against
Aaron Hernandez and I don't know how
much this would be exempt under
Massachusetts law if he has a recovery
but you're going to have three other
sets of lawyers very aggressively trying
to get every dollar they can to
compensate the victims of Aaron
Hernandez murders and and even though he
was acquitted in two of the cases you
still can have a viable civil lawsuit
and he still could be found responsible
it probably will be found responsible
for killing those other two men but
could you see a scenario where the
Patriots settled out of court here no I
don't think the Patriots are inclined to
do anything when it comes to Aaron
Hernandez they have shunned him from the
moment he was arrested back in June of
2013 there's an issue that's still
pending regarding signing bonus money
that he had earned the moment he put pen
to paper in August of 2012 he had earned
that money and they haven't paid it all
to him and that's still caught up in
litigation between the NFL and the NFL
Players Association so I don't think the
Patriots do anything here other than
continue to fight and take the position
he's gotten every last dollar from the
organization that he's ever going to get
the Browns favored in Indianapolis what
does that mean what does that mean
here's the thing we assume and for good
reason based upon the Colts recent
history that they just completely
mismanaged thus Andrew Luck this
situation what if it wasn't mismanaged
what if they knew all along that he
wasn't going to be able to go into
September October maybe beyond and they
just sold the idea that he would be so
the fans wouldn't abandon ship so they
wouldn't fail to renew their season
tickets so they wouldn't be engaged with
the team this year I mean if I'm a Colts
fan I'm a season ticket I'm wondering
was I lied to here because there's a
point where not even the Colts in
confidence over the past several years
can match how bad this is where he
hasn't even practiced yet I mean I'm
over I'd say shut him down for the year
what why risk even bringing him back and
getting him hurt worse yeah at some
point
have to wonder how long will it take him
to get back into football form and what
is he coming back to and I know that if
you look at this and you're you're one
of the other players on the team and
then you're saying wait you're gonna
hold him out because you want to protect
him then what am I doing here you know
you're putting me out here on the field
as well
even though you've got all this money
invested in Aaron Andrew Luck it's a
weird situation here and I don't know at
what point do you say it's not worth
putting him back in for the rest of this
season and how will the fans react to
that Andrew Luck at what point do you
say get me the hell out of here but he
can't get out because of that contract
well I know he can't because of the
contract next year it becomes a little
bit easier from a salary cap standpoint
if they would want to make a move but
think about it if your quarterback who
is essentially an extension your
coaching staff if he's not all-in and
I'm not saying Andrew Luck would do this
because I don't think he's wired
to do this but if there would ever come
a day where there's a quarterback who
was bound up in one of these contracts
he's and he's stuck and he wants out and
the team says no the next logical step
is to save time I'm not showing up for
any of the offseason program good luck
getting ready for the season and I'm
only there for the mandatory minicamp
and I'm not staying late and I'm not
coming early and I'm not watching film
and I'm not going to inspire the rest of
my teammates to do the same and I'm not
gonna leave I'm gonna be I'm going to be
a robot that goes out there and passes
the football when I'm told to do so and
if that's how you want to do it fine
that's how we'll do it
yeah I didn't strike me as that kind of
kid no no it would be a hell of a story
if it would ever happen it were my son
I'd say hell yes get out of there I
don't want you to continue to be
subjected to you know orthopedic and
internal injuries and whatever else may
be happy to get beat up behind that
horrible offensive line when you look at
what peyton manning had in Indianapolis
and Tony Dungy and I talk about this all
the time
they had a murderer's row of talented
players around Peyton Manning and they
still only won one Super Bowl
the Colts what do they have around
Andrew Luck they got T Y Hilton all due
respect to everyone else on the roster
they don't have anything close to what
Peyton Manning enjoyed and they only won
one Super Bowl under Peyton that I'll
see you Sunday Mike all right Mike
Florio Pro Football Talk on NB
CSN pro-football talk.com the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience